no no no don't do not jump out do not
jump
out get your get on theing ground get on
theing ground now body cam video
captures the moments a Florida man leads
deputies on a high-speed chase with two
young children in the backseat of the
car hey hi you're okay you're okay hi
hi the incident happened on February 4th
in vucha County Florida police say they
were attempting to pull over driver
after noticing his registration was
expired but instead of pulling over the
driver sped
[Music]
off got 12f North down on 415 towards
Walmart going to
primary I had two cars in between must
just set up and I didn't see a take
off 51 it just passed me 4:15 north of
Saddle Club
drop 51 Central just went left through
the red light 4155 on to the Valia
County Sheriff's Office says after
chasing their suspect for 38 miles
authorities then deployed a stop stick
in an attempt to catch
him sck
[Applause]
hit
[Music]
sford
tiing the right
Lan the stop stick caused both passenger
side tires to come off the rims the
driver seemingly decides the chase can't
last any longer authorities are then
able to pull over the driver and that's
when they make the startling Discovery
don't do not not jump out do not jump
out get your get on theing ground get on
theing ground now back
[Music]
up you stay
there oh you got a kid in the car
too authorities are able to Cuff the
driver and take him off in the back of a
squad car before tending to the crying
children who were along for the
terrifying ride driver secure two
infants in the back
seat we didn't have
to double lock his
[Applause]
cuffs hey hi you're okay you're okay hi
hi hi you're all right here come here
come here come here you're okay it's
going to be all right you're okay hey
hiy look look
whoa whoa you see that what is that what
is that right there what is that is that
helicopter
waa oh my goodness
[Music]
wow you like
helicopters yeah look color is
it white yeah good
job good job it's
white
wow
wow wow does it does it have
green is it white and
green you're
okay are you eating cookies you're all
right she said
no
the driver was identified as 25-year-old
Timothy Breedlove officials say in
addition to the two young children in
the back seat who were not injured
during the chase the children's mother
who was in the passenger seat reportedly
asked breed love to stop breed Love
Faces several charges as a result of the
chase he's charged with fleeing or
attempting to elude law enforcement two
counts of aggravated child abuse three
counts of false imprisonment and driving
with a suspended license the Valia
County Sheriff's Office says he was also
issued citations for fleeing running red
light expired vehicle registration and
driving with a suspended license we want
to thank Morgan and Morgan for
sponsoring today's LA crime YouTube
takeover if you've seen our videos you
know Morgan and Morgan is a proud
sponsor of ours I mean look our content
proves the world isn't always safe it
can be scary and when you're hurt it can
be confusing and you might not know
where to turn well Morgan and Morgan
America's largest injury Law Firm can
help you there isn't a day that goes by
I don't have my phone on me and with
just one click on your phone you you can
submit a claim and your injury could be
worth millions plus if you're in a rush
it only takes a few minutes to see if
you have a case and look Morgan and
Morgan doesn't settle for lowball offers
in the past couple of months they've
gotten verdicts of 12 million in Florida
26 million in Philly and 6.8 million
right here in New York all of these by
the way were significantly higher than
the highest insurance offer so if you're
injured you can start by easily
submitting a claim at www.
forthepeople.com youout takeover or by
dialing pound law that's pound 529 on
your phone meanwhile some suspects find
a clever yet dangerous way to evade from
police we're in Georgia next where dash
camera video shows the moments a driver
jumps out of a moving car before it
crashes into a local home dri dead stand
by
[Music]
for it happened in fet County Georgia
authorities say the driver stole a
silver Kia sedan leading deputies on a
high-speed chase passing several cars
weaving in and out of traffic with
speeds nearing 90 M an hour 2169 behind
it corth road coming up to
85 be making a right towards Clayton
k
2169 108 85 South passing Fun
Spot 1080 passing Fun Spot 85 sou
1429 U-turn 85 North going towards
corth right on
corent
Corinth Road speeds 50 coming up to
[Music]
Carter just about lost control at Carter
passing for drive at this time 42 M
hour
speeds are 87 passing River
Miss Crossing back in the FED passing
Curve Road speeds
88 passing cars in a curve double yellow
in front of Bara B Church speeds
81 if you could go ahead and notify
Clayton County going towards Highway 54
while passing through local
neighborhoods the driver narrowly avoids
being hit by oncoming traffic and then
picks the speed back up to the triple
digits yellow FR 64 mph coming up to 54
[Music]
coming up to the light 54 cor going
left going towards Clinton
[Music]
County Crossing into Clayton County
speed 100 crossing the bridge at the
county line
[Music]
now coming up to Mundy's Mill speeds 90
going straight across Mundy's Mill
towards ter Boulevard you
bu 22 46 myself and 24 not to more
behind we got
all speed 115 and climbing
120 be passing wy's Lake
Trail what driving
conditions light traffic for now speeds
100 passing Highway Drive Highway
Drive
[Music]
be passing swamp Oak Drive making a
right which is a dead end Street as a
driver heads toward a dead end that's
when he'll do all he can to evade
capture even if that means jumping out
of a moving vehicle Country Place swamp
Creek swamp Creek Drive dead end stand
by for a
bush
fo got one while the car crashed into a
nearby home it's unclear if anyone was
inside at the time of the crash or if
anyone was hurt the fet County Sheriff's
Office says they were later able to
capture the suspect but it's unclear
What charges that person faced next
we're in Toledo Ohio where a suspect
took authorities on a chase and and
allegedly pointed a gun at officers
while they ran after him the incident
happened on January 30th according to
police detectives with the Toledo gang
task force were conducting a traffic
stop on the driver of the vehicle Ari
hall Jones authorities say they were
alerted that hall Jones was in
possession of a firearm which he's not
allowed to have because he's a convicted
felon once detectives approached the
vehicle during the stop they spotted a
firearm prompting hall Jones to take off
the suspect took police on a nearly 2
Mile Chase through rainy and slippery
conditions but the chase was shortlived
after he crashed into a tree and took
off this time on foot body cam video
from one of the officers then captures
police in pursuit of hall Jones
according to Toledo PD hall Jones ran
off with the gun in hand and pointed it
at officers prompting them to fire at
him sh fire sh
fire
over shot
fire police are able to catch up to
their suspect to cuff him and he denied
even pointing a weapon at
officers you shoot at I never shot at Jo
I never shot a shot I what is you
talking about you shot at me for no
reason the no I didn't I never no gun
stand up stand
up
one
two bro come on I'm not even doing
nothing bro
like y just shot at me for no reason bro
drink face I never I never pointed no
gun at you ever like step your foot out
of the tree to kill me
like
hey
1150 everyone's in C see we got
him here's uh no one
shot at this time after police put hall
Jones in the back of a police car he was
taken off to the Lucas County Jail
facing multiple felony charges he was
charged with having a weapon while under
indictment failure to comply improperly
handling firearms and resisting arrest
while brandishing a deadly weapon a
judge later set his bond at
$55,000 and finally we're in East
Hartford Connecticut where body cam
video shows Police pulling over a
speeding driver only to find the driver
is one of their own how you do man I'm
Lieutenant Eastford charge of Traffic
Division what' I do you're just going a
little faster you could you could tell
that from where you were parked yeah
really yes sir oh okay am I good to go
yes thanks man have a good one day the
incident happened in September 2022
according to local reports Rocky Hill
Police initiated a traffic stop when the
officer approached the vehicle East
Hartford Police police Lieutenant Joe
ficacelli who was off duty at the time
decided to flash his badge after the
exchange the lieutenant was let go
without warning or even a citation fast
forward nearly 2 years later he was
arrested for alleged drunk driving
according to State Police he was
arrested in late January after he and a
retired officer were apparently driving
in the same car and at some point
switched seats before they were both
arrested ficacelli was reportedly taken
to a hospital after complaining about
being in pain but once at the hospital
he refused to take the standardized
field sobriety test the Rocky Hill
Police Department later released a
statement saying in part after reviewing
the body cam the Lieutenant's actions
warranted notification to his
Department's Command Staff he Harford
police officials say F aell has been
placed on administrative Duty he
scheduled to appear in court on February
13th reporting for long crime I'm
Elizabeth Milner